Hallo, guten Tag. Ich möchte mich kurz vorstellen, ich heiße Sheyma Karakashli.
Ich bin auf diese Sitzungsassistenz erstentätig und würde gerne mit Ihnen dieses Aufnahmegespräch führen.
Wenn Sie etwas nicht verstehen, bitte sagen Sie mir Bescheid.
Vielen Dank, Frau Dr. Karakashli, ein schwieriger Name.
Ja, leider.
Ich freut mich sehr, aber Sie sprechen fließend Deutsch. Ich glaube, Sie sind Neue hier in Deutschland?
Oder wo kommen Sie her, Frau Dr.?
Also in der Türkei bin ich hierhergekommen, also vor ungefähr neun Monaten.
Okay, und?
Ja, kurz zum Ablauf.
Herzlich Willkommen.
Vielen Dank.
Kurz zum Ablauf werde ich zuerst Ihre persönliche Daten abfragen, dann Ihre aktuelle Bescheiden am Ende ein paar Informationen über Ihre Familie.
Wie heißen Sie denn?
Mein Name ist Melanie Rosberg.
Könnten Sie bitte Ihre Vorunachnahme langsam uchsebirn?
Melanie, Martha, Emil, Ludwig, Anton, North Pole, Ida, Emil.
Melanie, Rosberg, ganz einfach, Richard Otto Siegfried, Baby Bertha, Emil, Erwe Richard und Gewe Gustav Rosberg.
Okay, Frau Rosberg.
Wie alt sind Sie und wie groß sind Sie?
Ich bin 49 Jahre alt.
Ich bin circa 1 Meter 65.
Wie viel wiegen Sie?
Oh, ein bisschen zu viel, Frau Dr. also ich war letzte Woche auf der Waage, das sind circa 95 Kilo.
Okay.
Was für Sie zu uns, Frau Rosberg?
Frau Dr. ich habe seit einigen Tagen so ziehende Schmerzen im linken Unterbau.
Und das wird immer stärker und daher wollte ich mich vorstellen, weil mir das so langsam etwas Angst macht.
Okay.
Linkende Unterbauchschmerzen.
Linke, also Schmerzen im linken Unterbau.
Okay.
Strahlen diese Schmerzen irgendwo hinaus?
Also manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, das strahlt in die Leiste aus.
Und manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, es kommt von der Flanke, also im Bereich der Nieren.
Aber es ist mehr im Unterbau.
Gibt es etwas, dass diese Schmerzen lindert oder verschlechtert?
Haben Sie bemerkt?
Also ich habe in den ersten Tagen, hat mir eine Wärmeflasche manchmal geholfen.
Ich schmerz auch nicht mehr.
Und die Schmerzen sind sehr unterschiedlich.
Die kommen so wellenartig. Man ist sehr stark und krampfartig und kolikartig.
Und manchmal sind sie eher so dumpf und wenig.
Aber jetzt nehmen die Schmerzen zu.
Da fällt mir noch ein, wenn ich auf Toilette gehen muss und ich eine Presse machen,
dann werden die Schmerzen schlimmer.
Also beim Stuhlgang.
Wie stark sind diese Schmerzen auf eine Schmerzskala 0 bis 10?
Wobei 0 kein Schmerz, um 10 sehr starker Schmerz ist.
Also am Anfang waren sie ganz wenig.
Aber gestern, so zwischen 5 und 7.
Haben Sie dagegen eine Medikamente ein?
Eingenommen?
Normalerweise hilft mir dann Paracetamol immer ganz gut.
Da habe ich jetzt verstärkt die letzten Tage genommen mit Paracetamol.
Paracetamol hat jetzt nicht geholfen?
Es hält immer weniger an.
Ich brauche jetzt mehr Tabletten, damit die Schmerzen einigermaßen erträglich sind.
Also ich brauche jetzt schon 3 bis 4 Paracetamol am Tag.
Hatten Sie ähnliche Beschwerden früher auch?
Nein, das ist das erste Mal.
Können Sie jetzt diese Schmerzen ertragen oder soll ich Ihnen eine Schmerz mit ergeben?
Ich glaube, Sie sind schon sehr stark, aber ich kann Sie noch ertragen, bis du zu suchen, bis fertig ist.
Das wäre auf jeden Fall für die Diagnose besser.
Haben Sie Blut im Urin gemacht?
Das nicht, aber ich merke seit gestern so leichtes Brennen beim Wasserlassen.
Aber Urin, also Blut, ist mir jetzt nicht aufgefallen.
Ich würde ein paar Fragen zu Ihren Vorbefinden stellen.
Haben Sie Fieber oder fühlen Sie sich fiebrig?
Ja, wo Sie das so ansprechen, seit gestern.
Ich hatte gestern Abend 38,2.
Dann war es nach der Paracetamol besser.
Heute Morgen habe ich auch wieder 37,9.
Da habe ich extra gemessen.
Ich fühle mich auch etwas schlapp und ein bisschen kränklich.
Haben Sie in der letzten Zeit abgenommen?
Nein, das wäre schön, wenn ich abgenommen hätte, aber nein.
Sind Ihnen Nachtschweiß oder Schüttelfrost aufgefallen?
Nein, das hatte ich jetzt nicht.
Leiden Sie unter Herzklopfen, Herzrasen, Husten oder Atomot?
Nein, das hatte ich bisher nicht.
Nein, ich bin eigentlich bisher relativ gesund.
Haben Sie geschwollene Beine bemerkt?
Nein, meine Beine sind schon etwas dick, sage ich mal.
Aber eine Zunahme habe ich jetzt nicht bemerkt.
Nein, oder Wasser in den Beinen habe ich auch nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Sturldang?
Nein, bisher ist eigentlich alles in Ordnung.
Wie ist Ihre Appetit?
Bisher ganz gut, also ich habe mir bisher noch keine Sorgen.
Leiden Sie unter Übelkeit oder Erbrechen?
Gestern merke ich eine leichte Übelkeit, aber erbrochen habe ich jetzt nicht.
Haben Sie Probleme beim Ein- oder Durchlaufen?
Nein, das klappt ja freulicherweise ganz gut.
Ich trinke immer meinen Brennessel-Tee am Abend und das hilft mir ganz gut.
Wie viele Liter am Tag trinken Sie am Tag?
Ach, ich versuche schon auf meine 2 Liter zu kommen, ja.
Das klappt auch meistens ganz gut.
Ich würde ein paar Fragen zu Ihrer Vorgeschichte stellen.
Leiden Sie unter krönschen Erkrankungen, Herr Frau Rosberg?
Also ich habe einen Blutdruck seit circa 5 Jahren, dann nehme ich auch Medikamente.
Und krönschen Erkrankungen, ich habe immer wieder chronische Gastritie,
also Magenschlanghautentzündung, und da hatte ich jetzt auch vor circa 6 Jahren
eine Magenspiegelung.
Und in diesem Rahmen bekam ich auch eine Darmspiegelung.
Die war ein Ordnung, aber da hieß es, ich habe so viele Ausbuchtungen im Darm,
das nennt sich die vertikulose, glaube ich.
Aber bisher habe ich keine Beschwerden gehabt.
Was nehmen Sie regelmäßig oder bei Bedarf?
Also welche Medikamente haben Sie?
Mit dem Blutdruck habe ich Ramipril.
Wie viel Milligramm?
Bitte?
Ich habe noch 5 Milligramm.
Dann nehme ich eine Morgens und eine 5 Milligramm am Abend.
Und seit einem halben Jahr hat mir der Doktor noch mal ein weiteres Medikament gegeben,
das nennt sich Amlodipine.
Dann nehme ich morgens eine Tablette.
Wie viel Milligramm nehmen Sie ein?
Ich glaube, das sind auch 5 Milligramm.
Das war's, oder?
Ja, das reicht mal so.
Das finde ich eigentlich nicht.
Wurden Sie schon mal operiert oder stationär behandelt?
Auch dass ich länger zurück.
Ich wurde vor ca. 20 Jahren mal an einer Emblemetriose operiert.
Aber seitdem ist alles in Ordnung.
Und ich glaube, ich habe als Kind auch der Blinddarm operiert worden.
Ansonsten habe ich immer wieder so kleinere Sportverletzungen mal gehabt,
aber das waren jetzt keine größeren Sachen.
Sind bei Ihnen irgendwelche Allergien oder Unverträglichkeit bekannt?
Nein, bisher nicht.
Alles gut.
Sind Sie vollständig geimpft?
Ja, also da bin ich sehr dahinter.
Meine Hausärztin hat alle Impfungen gemacht.
Ich bin auch gegen Corona geimpft, bin auch geboostert.
Die sind komplett meine Impfungen.
Sie stellen aber viele Fragen vor Doktor.
Wie lange dauert das Gespräch denn noch?
Ja, ich weiß, aber ich muss diese Fragen stellen,
um eine Abschließung der Diagnose zu stellen.
Ich bitte Sie jetzt um etwas Geduld.
Ich brauche alle diese Informationen.
Okay.
Wie ist Ihre Monatsblutung?
Bisher regelmäßig. Da habe ich keine Probleme.
Wann war alles das mein?
War zuvor drei Wochen.
Gehen Sie regelmäßig zum Frauenarzt?
Ja, ich gehe einmal im Jahr regelmäßig zur Untersuchung.
Alles in Ordnung?
Bisher keine Probleme.
Okay, super.
Lassen Sie uns über Ihre Lebensgewohnheiten sprechen.
Rachen Sie?
Nein.
Trinken Sie regelmäßig Alkohol?
Nein, han sich jetzt nicht, aber ab und zu mal,
wenn eigentlich Feiern oder Anlässe sind,
dann trinke ich mal ein Gläschen Wein,
aber das kann wirklich nichts sein.
Okay.
Haben Sie Kontakt mit dem Drogen?
Also meine größte Droge sind Haribos.
Ich will nicht halten, aber ansonsten andere Drogen
habe ich jetzt bisher nicht mehr.
Okay.
Ja, leben Ihre Alten, oder?
Ja, die leben in Kassel,
denen geht es gut, also die sind schon alt,
aber sie sind noch relativ fit.
Okay.
Also haben die Eltern keine Vorerkrankungen
oder Krönchenerkrankungen?
Kennen Sie?
Typische Altersöcher haben,
ich glaube, die haben Blutdruck
und meine Mutter hat wohl
einen leichten, beginnenden Diabetes anscheinend,
aber sie sind eigentlich recht fit.
Beide Eltern haben eine Tochterung.
Ja.
Haben Sie Geschwister?
Ich habe einen Bruder.
Ist er gesund?
Ja, der ist topfit.
Wie ist Ihr Familienstand?
Ich wohne alleine, ich bin geschieden
und ich arbeite als IT-Managerin
in einer Firma
und habe keine Kinder.
Wir haben alle Fragen beantwortet.
Habst du mir schon gedacht, dass Sie das wissen?
Ja.
Ja, letzte Frage, wie heißt Ihre Hausarzt?
Das ist die Frau Dr. Müller
in Frankenthal.
Okay.
Ja, Frau Rosberg, ich habe
alle wichtige Fragen gestellt.
Haben Sie Fragen oder möchten Sie hinzufügen?
Nein, nein, als ich möchte, die Schmerzen werden schlimmer.
Vielleicht sollte man doch eine Infusion geben,
so wie Sie das vorhin vorgeschlagen haben.
Aber im Moment habe ich
keine anderen Frauen.
Ich lege jetzt einen Zugang
und bekomme Sie eine Schmerzmitteil.
Ich werde jetzt die Körperhunter suchen.
Ich nehme die Blut und
die Urin-Probe ein.
Abnehmen?
Bitte?
Urin-Probe abnehmen.
Abnehmen.
Dann
Bauch-Ultraschall,
oder so.
Ja, und wenn alle befunden da sind,
können wir genau sagen, was Sie haben.
Jetzt liegen Sie sich bitte auch die Untersuchungsliege
und kommen zu Ihnen.
Wunderbar, vielen Dank.
Sehr gut, sehr gut, sehr gut.
Haben die Kollegen noch Fragen?
Oder sollen wir gleich zum Arzt-Arzt-Gespräch übergehen?
Brauen Sie noch eine Zeit, Frau Doktor,
für die Zusammenfassung?
Ja, vielleicht können wir machen.
Ja, über eine Minute,
dann können Sie Ihre Notizen mal lesen.
Wie oft gehen Sie zum Wasser lassen?
Okay, nicht so oft,
zwei bis dreimal am Tag.
Und der Urin ist normal.
Kein Blut ist nicht trüb, ist klar.
Weitere Fragen, keine Fragen, okay.
Die Kollegen können schon mal
Ihre Verdachtsdiagnosen aufschreiben.
Frau Doktor Schema, Sie gucken nicht.
Was denken die Kollegen?
Welche Erkrankung hat diese Patientin?
Hat keiner eine Idee?
Lageabhängig? Nein, nicht lageabhängig.
Also nicht sprechen, dass die Frau Schema das nicht hört,
sondern nur schreiben in den Chat.
Wo sind die Kollegen?
Ja, ich sehe hier eine Verdachtsdiagnose.
Nein, keine Diagnose.
Wo sind die Diagnosen?
Liebe Kolleginnen und Kollegen.
Pyrrhenephitis?
Nicht schrecklich aufschreiben, Herr Doktor.
Sonst geben Sie der Frau Doktor einige Tipps.
Also, wir haben 13 Doktoren.
So, bitte, ich möchte von allen eine Diagnose sehen.
Womit Abi?
Jetzt muss niemand talken.
Aber meine Kollegen,
es ist so, dass die Leute ein bisschen aufheben.
Hallo Herr Oberal.
Hallo, Herr Oberal.
Oberalte. Ah, meine Kollegin aus der Türkei, guten Tag Frau Doktor, was haben Sie, erzählen Sie?
Ja, ich habe eine neue Patientin aufgenommen. Ich möchte Ihnen den Fall vorstellen, haben Sie
kurze Zeit dafür? Aber natürlich für Sie doch immer Frau Doktor, bitte schön. Vielen, vielen Dank.
Frau Melanie Rosberg ist eine 49-jährige Patientin. Sie ist 1,65 Meter groß und 95 Kilo schwer.
Sie stellte sich bei uns, wegen seit einigen Tagen bestehende Wellenformige,
verlaufende, dumpfartige, kollegartige, trichende Unterbauchschmerzen mit Ausstrahlung in die
Leiste und Flanke vor. Die Schmerzintensität liegt bei 5 bis 7 auf einer Schmerzskalan von 0 bis 10.
Wärmeanwendung wurde ein bisschen geholfen, aber jetzt nicht mehr.
Wärmeanwendungen haben etwas geholfen. Wärmeanwendung habe wenig geholfen, jetzt nicht mehr.
Diese Schmerzen verschlechteren sich beim Stuhl. Sie nehmen Paracetamol ein, vier, fünf Mal am Tag.
Aber am Anfang habe Paracetamol geholfen, aber jetzt nicht mehr. Die Fragen wurden vorherrige
ähnliche Beschwerden beinleit. Sie haben Blut im Urin nicht bemerkt und klackte über brennende
Wasserlaufen. Leichte, eine leichte Dysurie. Und vegetative Anamnese. Sie habe Fieber. Gestern haben sie
382 gemessen und Paracetamol eingenommen. Und lindern sich der Fieber. Darunter habe sich das Fieber
gesenkt und die Schmerzen gelindert. Okay, ja, gesenkt. Und heute habe sie wieder gemessen und 379.
Okay, immer subfibril bis hohe Temperaturen. Ja, war. Okay. Die übliche vegetative Anamnese sei bis auf
Übelkeit, also nausea unauffällig. Und sie leide seit fünf Jahren unter Arterele
Hypertonie und nehme dagegen Ramipriir, fünf Milligramm, einmal morgens, einmal abends ein.
Und ja, und sie leide an chronische Gastritis. Ja, ein Amlodipin. Sie nehme Amlodipin, fünf Milligramm,
einmal morgens ein. Und sie leide unter chronische Gastritis und Divertglöse. Ja, vor 20 Jahren wurde sie
endometriose operiert. Und als Kind wurde eine Appendectomie durchgeführt. Und die Frage nach allergien
Verträglichkeiten wurden verneint. Und sie sei vollständig geimpft. Und genäkologisch
Anamnese sei unauffällig. Ihre letzte Periode ist vor drei Wochen. Und wie bitte? Vor drei Wochen
gewesen. Und Rahum und Drogenkonsum wurden verneint. Sie trinken Einglas Wein,
gelegentlich. Und ihre Mutter leide an Diabetes mellitus und Arterele Hypertonie. Sein Vater leide an
Arterele Hypertonie. Und sie habe ein Bruder, der gesund ist. Und sie ist geschieden und wohne allein.
Habe kein Kinder. Und sie sei IT-Managerin in einem Firma. Ja, laut der anamnestischen Angaben gehe ich von
Pioronephritis. Differenzial diagnostisch kommen die folgende Infrage. Nephrolitiasis.
Also, okay, ein Nierenstein, jawoll, was noch? Und Erolitiasis und Divertikulitis.
Woran denken Sie noch? Handwerksinfektion, ganz einfach. Ja, Handwerksinfektion. Woran denken Sie noch?
Ein gynecologischer Erkranknis. Agnexitis. Jawoll. Und ein Elius. Ja, Elius. Kann auch mal sein. Jawoll.
Und weitere gynecologische Diagnose, ovarial Züsten, kann natürlich auch mal sein. Aber das sind schon mal sehr viele, die schon mal sehr gut jawoll.
Wunderbar, das ist gut. Das ist eine Patientin, das war ein Patient, den ich hatte aus meiner Praxis. Der hat aber eine Divertikulitis gehabt.
Aber die, die es mit den Angaben kann, natürlich auch, ich habe auch zuerst gedacht, der hat ein Nierenstein oder einen Haarenleitstein.
Aber es war eine Divertikulitis. Welche Untersuchung lassen Sie durchführen, um genau zu klären, was das ist?
Wir haben Blut abgenommen, da ist ein CRP von über 200. Leukos sind bei 17.000 und alles andere war in Ordnung.
Hat Fieber, also hat eine Entzündung. Aber Sie möchten wissen, ist es ein Haarenleitstein oder ein Nierenstein oder Divertikulitis? Welche Untersuchung möchten Sie haben?
Sie haben auch Ultraschall gemacht, das ist auch in Ordnung, da sehen Sie nichts. Die Niere ist in Ordnung, keine Aufstau.
Klopfschall oder?
Nein, keine Kondoskopie davor.
Nicht körperlich untersuchen, eine Bildgebung möchten Sie.
Computerdomographie?
Genau, das geht sehr schnell und Sie haben eine gute Aussage.
In der Computerdomographie hat man gesehen, er hat wirklich eine sehr ausgeprägte Divertikulitis.
In der Darmspiegelung wird man das nicht erkennen, eine Computerdomographie.
Wenn Nierensteine vorliegen, dann sieht man die auch sehr gut.
Und von daher immer erst mal eine Computerdomographie.
Sehr gut. Wie behandeln Sie jetzt diese Divertikulitis?
Wir haben jetzt einen CT gemacht und gesehen, es ist eine Divertikulitis.
Wie ist die Divertikulitis?
Antibiotische Therapie.
Sehr gut.
Schmerzmedikation?
Ja, und Sie haben Fieber, also Zupfabri.
Meistens sind die Schmerzmedikamente auch Fieber senkend.
Welches Schmerzmedikamente würden Sie geben?
Paracetamol und es hilft nicht.
Wo sind die Tänisten?
Hilfen Sie mal. Metamizol, Jawohl. Metamizol ist welches Medikament?
Frau Doktofib, der ist antwortet sehr toll.
Nicht Tara Damol, sondern Tramadol nennt sich das.
Tramadol ist auch gut, aber ich würde erst mal Tramadol.
Nicht tro.
Ich würde mit Novalgin anfangen und wenn das nicht reicht, kann man noch Tramadol dazu geben.
Sehr gut.
Was muss man bei der Divertikulitis beachten?
Was kann bei einer Divertikulitis auftreten?
Perforation oder...
Sehr gut. Das heißt, es kann zu einer Perforation kommen.
Und woran erkennen Sie das? Man hat freie Luft.
Auch, Hülle, was muss man dann machen?
Operation.
Antibiotische Abdeckung, Schmerzmedikation und wenn eine Perforation folgt,
dann muss man operieren.
Das entscheidet aber der Chirurg.
Das heißt, da müssen Sie den Patienten den Chirurgen vorstellen.
Super.
Sehr gut. Was machen Sie bei einem Nierenstein?
Stein.
Okay.
Ja.
Zuerst Medikamentöse...
Und Ologenschicken.
Ologenschicken.
Sie schicken.
Was macht der Orologe? Der gibt erst mal einen Schmerzmedikament.
Und ESWL.
Also extrakorporeale Schwellen.
Ja.
In der Akuttherapie würde man erst mal Schmerzmedikamente, Antibiotika, geben.
Und diese ESWL macht man bei Nierensteinen.
Artenleitersteinen, wenn der Stein aus der Niere raus ist
und in der Hanleiter feststeckt,
dann wartet man erst mal, dass es von alleine weggeht.
Und wenn dieser Hanleiterstein nicht von alleine abläuft oder weggeht,
dann muss man diese mit einer Schlinge herausholen.
Überall.
Okay.
Eine Schlinge.
Sehr gut.
Ich glaube, das war jetzt genug, oder?
Wir wollen Sie jetzt nicht zu sehr...